hello everyone so here i'd like to talk
about harmonic functions
now harmonic functions are a very
special kind of multivariable function
and they're defined in terms of the
laplacian which i've been talking about
in the last few videos so the laplacian
which we denote with this upper right
side up triangle
is a as an operator that you might take
on a multivariable function so it might
have two inputs it could have you know
100 inputs just some kind of
multivariable function with a scalar
output and i talked about in the last
few videos but as a reminder it's
defined as the divergence of the
gradient of f
and it's kind of like the second
derivative it's sort of the way to
extend the idea of the second derivative
into multiple dimensions now what a
harmonic function is is one where the
laplacian is equal to zero and it's
equal to zero at every possible input
point and sometimes the way that people
uh write this to distinguish it they'll
make it kind of a triple equal sign
maybe saying like equivalent to zero and
this is really just a way of emphasizing
that it's equal to zero at all possible
input points it's you know not an
equation that you're solving for the
specific x and y where it equals zero
it's a statement about the function
and to get our head around this because
it's kind of a you know as you're just
starting to learn about the laplacian
it's hard to just immediately see the
intuition for what this means um let's
think about what it means for a single
variable function if you just have some
single variable function of x and you're
looking at its second derivative which
is kind of the analog of the laplacian
what does it mean if that's equal to
zero
well we can integrate it we can take the
anti-derivative and say that means that
the single derivative of f
well let's see what functions have a
derivative that's zero
the only functions are the constant ones
so c is just going to mean some constant
here and if you integrate that again and
say what function has as its derivative
a constant
well it's going to be that constant
times x plus some other constant some
other constant k
so basically linear functions so if
you're thinking of a graph it's just
something that's got a line line passing
through it like that and this should
kind of make sense if you think of the
geometric interpretation for the second
derivative because if you're just
looking at a random you know arbitrary
function this kind of curving as it does
the second derivative is
negative when this concavity is down so
this right here would be a point where
the second derivative it's not zero it's
negative and over here when the
concavity is up and it's got a sort of
bowl shape that's where the second
derivative is positive
so if we're saying that the second
derivative has to always be zero then it
can't curve down and it can't curve up
and it can't do that anywhere so
basically there's no curving allowed so
whatever whatever direction it starts at
it's not allowed to curve so it just
sticks stick straight like that
but once we extend this to the idea of a
multi-variable function things can get a
lot more interesting than just a
straight line so an example i've got the
graph here of a multivariable function
that happens to be harmonic so the graph
that you're looking at this is of a two
variable function
and the function specifically is
f of x y
x y
is equal to e to the x multiplied by
sine of y
and as we're looking at the graph here
hopefully it makes a little bit of sense
why this is sort of an e to the x sine
of y pattern because as we're moving in
the positive x direction this here is
the positive x direction you have this
exponential shape and this corresponds
with the fact that over here we've got
an e to the x so as you move x it kind
of looks like e to the x and it's being
multiplied by something that is a
function of y so if you're holding y
constant this just looks like a constant
but notice if that was a if that was a
negative constant if sine of y at some
point happens to be negative then your
your whole exponential function actually
kind of goes down it's sort of like a
negative e to the x look
but if you imagine moving in the y
direction so instead of the pure x
direction like that if we imagine
ourselves moving um
with the input going along let's see
what would be it would be this way
positive y direction you have this sort
of sinusoidal shape
and that should make sense because
you've got the sine of y and depending
on what e to the x is the amplitude of
that sine wave is going to get you know
really high at some points here it's
going way up and way down but if e to
the x was really small you know it
hardly hardly even looks like it's
wiggling over here it's pretty much
looks flat so that's that's the graph
that we're looking at and i'm telling
you right now i claim that this is
harmonic this is a function whose
laplacian is equal to zero and what that
would mean is that as we go over here
and we say
we evaluate the laplacian of f
which um just to remind you there's a
different formula rather than thinking
divergence of gradient that turns out to
be completely the same as saying you
take the second derivative of that
function with respect to x that's its
first input and you add that let's say
second derivative with respect to x you
add that to the second derivative of
your function with respect to the next
variable and you keep doing this for all
of the different variables that there
are but this is just a two variable
function so you do this twice the claim
is that this is always equal to zero so
i might say kind of equivalent at every
possible input it's equal to zero
um and i think i'll leave that as
something for for you to compute it
might be kind of good practice to kind
of get a feel for uh computing laplacian
but what i want to do is interpret what
does this actually mean right because
you can plug it through and you can see
ah yes at all possible inputs it will be
zero but what does that mean because in
the single variable context
once we started thinking about the
geometric interpretation of a second
derivative as this concavity it sort of
made sense that forcing it to be zero
will give us a straight line but clearly
that's not the case this is much more
complicated than a straight line
and for that i want to give a kind of a
different way that you can think about
the single variable second derivative on
the one hand you can think of let's say
negative second derivative as being this
concavity where it's kind of frowning
down but another way you could maybe
think about this is saying that all of
the neighbors of your point if you go a
little bit to the left right you're
you've got an input point here and if
you go a little bit to the left the
neighbor is less than it and if you go a
little bit to the right that other
neighbor is also less than it so it's
kind of a way of saying hey if you look
at the neighbors of your input so if you
if you happen to be making the claim
that f double prime at some particular
input like x sub o
is less than zero it's saying that all
of the neighbors of x sub o all of the
neighbors of that point are less than it
and if you do a similar thing over at a
positive concavity point where it's kind
of smiling up you say well its neighbor
to the right has a greater value and its
neighbor to the left has a greater value
so at some point where the the second
derivative instead of being less than
zero happens to be um
happens to be greater than zero that
means that the neighbors tend to be
greater than the point itself and even
if you're looking at a circumstance that
isn't this idealized you know it happens
to be a local minimum but let's say
you're looking at a graph
let's say you're looking at a function
at a point where it's concave up right
it's concave up but um it's not this
idealized local minimum kind of
circumstance so instead you might be
looking at a point like this and if you
look at you know it's neighbor to the
left that'll have some value that's
actually less than your original guy so
the neighbor looks like it's less than
it on the left but if you move that same
distance to the right its neighbor is
greater but you would say on average if
you took the average value of the
neighbors the neighbor on the right kind
of out balances the neighbor on the left
and you would say on average its
neighbors are greater than the than the
point itself so let's say that input
point there was like x sub o that would
mean that the second derivative of your
function at that point
you know is greater than zero
so with this positive concavity you can
also think of it as a measure of on
average are the neighbors greater than
your original point or less than it and
the reason i'm saying this is because
this idea of kind of comparing your
neighbors to the original point is a
much better way to contemplate the
laplacian in the multivariable world so
if we look at a function like this and
let's say we're looking at it kind of
from a bird's eye view
so we've got our xy plane right this
over here is the x-axis and this up here
is the y-axis and let's say that we're
looking at some specific input point
with the laplacian you want to start
thinking about a circle of points around
it all of its neighbors and in fact
think of a perfect circle so all of the
points that are specified distance away
the question the laplacian is asking is
hey are those neighbor points on average
greater than or less than your original
point
and this is actually this is how i
introduced the laplacian in the original
video where i was giving kind of the
intuition for the laplacian um you're
asking do the points around a given
input happen to be greater than it or
less than it and if you're looking at a
point where the laplacian of your
function happens to be greater than zero
at some point that would mean all of the
neighbors tend to be on average greater
than your point whereas if you're
looking at a point where the laplacian
of your function
is less than zero then all of those
neighbors on average would be less than
your point so in particular you know if
the laplacian was less than zero you
might your point might look like a local
maximum or if the laplacian was greater
than zero it might look like a local
minimum because all of its neighbors
would be greater than where it is but
for harmonic functions what makes them
so special is that you're saying
the the value of the function itself or
the value of the laplacian of the
function at every possible point is
equal to zero so no matter what point
you choose those neighbors are going to
be
on average the same value as this guy so
the height of the graph above those
neighbors will on average be the same
so
so if we kind of look around the graph
what that should mean is let's say
you're looking at an input point you
know the output of this guy and if you
looked at all of its the circle of its
neighbors and kind of projected them up
onto the graph what it should mean is
that the height of all the points on the
circle on average are the same as that
and no matter where you look that should
kind of average out and again i
encourage you to take a look at take a
look at this function and actually
evaluate the laplacian to see that it's
zero but what's interesting is it's not
at all clear just looking at this e to
the x times sine of y formula that the
average value of a circle of input
points is always going to kind of equal
the value of the point at the center
that's not something you can easily tell
just looking at that formula but with
what's not that hard a computation you
can make this conclusion which is pretty
far-reaching and this comes up all the
time in physics
you know for example heat is one where
maybe you want to describe how the heat
at a certain point in a room is related
to the average value of the heat of all
of the points kind of around it and in
fact it comes up in all sorts of
circumstances where you have some point
in physical space and something about
that point maybe like the rate at which
some property of it is changing
corresponds to the average value at
points around it so whenever you're sort
of relating neighbors to your original
point the laplacian comes in and
harmonic functions have this tendency to
correspond to some notion of stability
and i won't go deeper into that now this
is really
that really starts to get into the topic
of partial differential equations but at
least in the context of just
multi-variable calculus i wanted to shed
some light on interpreting this operator
and kind of interpreting the
physical and geometric properties that
that that implies about a function and
with that
i will see you next video